what are your daily non-negotiable
habits way fabin my daily non-negotiable
habits and usually I want to sleep in
about 10:30 10:30 a.m. style just eat
some donuts listen I mean I the the at
the end of the day this when he goes
freedom it's a mantra that I learned
from you and that it's just absolutely
true and if you got a you got to get up
in the morning and work out on there's
some days I frankly I can't do that cuz
life gets in the way whether I'm if I'm
traveling or my kid wakes up early and I
know I've been out of town and my wife
wants to get a workout in before the day
starts so I've to take the kids so she
can do that and we can we can rotate out
you know so I can't tell you that always
happens but you got to get up early you
got to work out and you have to you have
to prioritize and execute and having
that checklist that you put together the
night before about what you want to do
and what's important is is absolutely
critical otherwise you lose it and you
know for me and Jocko and for all of us
in our team on national on front like
it's when we get away from the things
that we talk about the people we're
human beings like everybody else and we
can get pulled in different directions
when we get away from those things it
doesn't work things start to fall apart
you lose you lose track of where the
priorities all right if I can't
regularly detach that's something that I
have to really focus on to do is is to
regularly detach if I'm grinding on
something for two or three or four hours
at a time sometimes it's easy to miss
other things that are better coming up
and I gotta make sure I pull away from
things kind of kind of think about the
prioritizing IceCube piece figure out
you know if I need to reprioritize and
so I don't get target fixated on one
thing and and keep going but I think for
me you know I what I want to do is I try
to make time to spend time with my
family as much as I can as well and
obviously there's there's a there's a
lot of work to do there always is and
and it's you know those things the the
the one when when I can stay consistent
on getting up early in the morning
getting a workout in you know stay
focused on a list that I have from the
night before that I'm falling through
all the things you talk about that's I'm
performing better than I ever do also
when it works at the end of it is what
works and there's what doesn't work yeah
that's how you win check